das thema schwebt ja schon über den
ganzen abend also wir haben wir haben
große herausforderungen wir haben
entlastungs paket auf den weg gebracht
wir müssen uns aber auch das haben wir
auch jetzt schon mehrfach heute
festgestellt der staat kann nicht
unendlich
inflations preisentwicklung abfedern
wollen ausgeglichenen haushalt haben die
schuldenbremse wieder einhalten deswegen
müssen wir uns da ehrlich machen wir
müssen sagen dass wir unsere
hausaufgaben als staat machen müssen wir
den anspruch an die ampel regierung aber
auch an alle landesregierungen an alle
landesparlamente und wir müssen wieder
wachstumsimpulse in diesem land setzen
das heißt wir müssen wenn wir in
inflation bekämpfen wollen in
deutschland zunächst erst mal sagen die
originäre aufgabe die bei europäischen
zentralbank ist unabhängig es wird aber
das kann man dennoch sagen es ist
überfällig dass wir hier das zinsniveau
an
an die realität anpassen das wird
vielleicht auch diese woche bereits
beginnt passieren und der staat muss
alles dazu tun dass dieser preisdruck
abgefedert wird das wichtigste ist dass
wir seriöse finanzen in deutschland
haben deswegen einhaltung der
schuldenbremse es heißt aber auch dass
wir zum beispiel über
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz und das
mache momentan mit den lng terminals an
der nordsee es gibt plötzlich sehr
schnell ergibt plötzlich einen externen
druck haben über den ukraine krieg dass
wir andere form der gaslieferung
benötigen da sind planungsverfahren
plötzlich bestürmen beschleunigt und das
müssen wir so auch bei ganz ganz vielen
anderen
infrastrukturmaßnahmen durchsetzen dass
die diskussion die wir im herbst führen
müssen wir müssen dazu kommen dass der
freihandel wieder mehr ermöglichen zeta
das freihandelsabkommen mit kanada ist
ein klassisches beispiel das ist
ausverhandelt das könnte man
unterschreiben um hier mit handel
entsprechenden wohlstand auch wieder in
deutschland zu sichern einer
zwischenfrage als bürgerin stellen
stark gefährdet ist denn unser wohlstand
also wir reden darüber was man machen
muss aber wie brenzlig ist die lage die
lage und steinlage die lage ist so hoch
es ist so brenzlig der inflationsrate
von 8 prozent fast acht prozent haben
dass sich das in das vermögen von uns
allen rein frisst je nachdem welche
anlagen wenn man vermögen hat ob
immobilien oder sachwerte man besitzt
und deswegen ist eine inflationsrate von
acht prozent ein alarmsignal für uns
alle die volkswirte die
wirtschaftsweisen gehen davon aus dass
sich das ein wenig abflachen wird die
zielrichtung von zwei prozent wie es die
europäische zentralbank als als maßgabe
ausgegeben hat das wird aber sicherlich
im nächsten jahr auch nicht erreichbar
sein deswegen müssen wir gucken dass wir
zum einen entlasten strukturelle
entlastung dass lotte mehr von ihrem
lohn haben auf der anderen seite müssen
wir wachstum erzeugen damit
entsprechend
wir hier über
ein wachstum das nicht die
preisentwicklung anheizt unseren
wohlstand verteidigen aber sondern er
hat die inflation nicht schon weit vor
dem ukraine krieg eingesetzt wo ich all
die ezb-politik wenn durch die schweiz
kugel haben wir sag ich jetzt mal ein
trend der schweiz eine inflation von ich
glaube 23 man hängt nicht am ezb trotz
also japan importiert sich die inflation
dadurch dass der dollar immer immer
immer stärker wird beispielsweise und
natürlich hat die energiewende auch
schon im letzten jahr doch recht
inflation angereist waren auch eine
deutsche politisch gewünschte
entscheidung richtig vollkommen
vollkommen vollkommen richtig in der in
der analyse ja vollkommen richtig dass
die energiewende wie wir sie den letzten
jahren beschlossen haben zu preis
impulsen geführt hat vollkommen richtig
auch dass die ezb das haben wir auch
immer gesagt letzten jahren zu zaghaft
der preisentwicklung geschaut die
aktuelle lage hier meine fragen damit
frau bald auch zu wort kommen und
herdorf damit wir das noch einmal
verbreiten ihre ihre these hier frau
bald merken sie denn schon die inflation
ist ihr wohlstand schon gefährdet ich
bin eine gut verdienende singlefrau
und hat dann keine probleme ja und fach
fahrrad und verregnet hatte ich kann
auch wahnsinnig gut mit geld umgehen das
habe ich von meinem vater gelernt aber
finanzbeamter ich kann auch wahnsinnig
gut passen und hoch die tassen ja ich
kann alles und ich bin halt auch
wahnsinnig fleißig ich habe gut wenn ich
mich trifft dann ist eben tucson aber
ich sehe dass man angestellten bei mir
ich habe teilweise stundenlohn erhöht
von 20 auf 25 euro
und wie gesagt man muss alles tun sonst
laufen sie dir davon ich war gestern mal
bei meiner besten freundin hier ist eine
österreicherinnen die hat ein
österreichisches restaurant wie gesagt
es sind 1500 stellen offen in berlin wir
kriegen keine leute ich zahl von 400
euro mehr als vorher ich habe jedes
gericht zwei euro teurer gemacht ich
meine es ist so wie der im zirkus der
amt heller mittelklasse und das alles
macht was soll ich gegen die inflation
ist immer irgendwo machtlos ist das
hieße im supermarkt ich weiß auch nicht
was butter kostete butter kauf also
das andere problem das wir haben wir
haben über 30 prozent zurzeit quote am
gibt also am bruttoinlandsprodukt also
wo soll das noch hinführen also wir
haben die höchste quote im moment ist
sie wird noch steigern leistung muss
sich wieder lohnen es gibt auch noch
wenig und dann ist der mittelstand und
das sind die arbeitnehmer nun aber
nimmer die das ganze finanzieren wir
müssen noch mal schauen dass wir da mal
eine eingrenzung kriegen also die arbeit
die leistung muss sich wieder lohnen
recht und wenn wir offene stellen haben
aber auf der anderen seite auch noch
einen relativ hohen arbeitslosen stand
da muss ich da etwas tun und ich kann
nicht immer mit formulierung und neuen
begriffen die quote immer weiter nach
unten ziehen weil sie rausnehmen aus der
aktuellen quote sondern da mussten wir
ganz stark reingehen dass wir nicht über
30 prozent so zeit gut da können wir uns
den sozialstaat den fetten starken
deutschen sozialstaat überhaupt noch
leisten nein ich glaube nicht also es
ist wie wir merken ja das ist in die an
die falsche richtung geht wenn wir jetzt
nicht langsam anfangen dort wieder daran
zu arbeiten dass der arbeitnehmer auch
weiß warum er das verdient und der
entsprechenden leistung bekommt ja dann
wohl dass sie letztes jahr wir haben im
bundeshaushalt gehen über 50 prozent in
den sozialtransfers gehen muss man aber
auch der ehrlichkeit sagen über 100 105
milliarden euro die mit zuschüssen in
die deutsche rentenversicherung das muss
man der ehrlichkeit dazu sagen die
konsequenz wenn wir das nicht über
direkte zuschüsse aus dem haushalt
finanzieren würden wäre dass wir die
rentenversicherungsbeiträge anheben
müssten deswegen glaube ich am ende des
tages hilft uns nur mehr wachstum wir
haben in den letzten jahren schon vor
diesem jahr festgestellt dass wir nicht
so schnell raus gekommen sind als
deutschland aus der pandemie was die
wachstumsraten angeht und da müssen wir
hinkommen wir müssen hin zu einer
angebots orientierten politik das heißt
wir müssen am ende des tages ist das was
ich sagte dass sie ja auch sagte eine
ahnung beschleunigen ist das liegt an
der ampel na ja man hat ja keine frage
die macht des faktischen
insgesamt 1005 gesagt es geht so nicht
weiter und wenn über zeitenwenden reden
darüber reden dass die grünen eine ganze
reihe vielleicht auch von ihren
lebenslügen im letzten monaten über bord
geworfen haben dann kann das ja
vielleicht auch sein dass man an der
einen stelle denn in der innenpolitik
sieht dass hier eine gewisse
beweglichkeit da ist am ende des tages
ist das nur der einzige weg den wir
haben wenn wir ganz klar die regeln die
wir uns gesetzt haben schuldenbremse
einhalten dann werden wir nur über
wachstums im handgriff dann sieht er
schon mal nicht so weit er gerade kurz
gesagt noch einmal die frage einfällt
wenn sie das jetzt hör mit dem beispiel
die sie gerade erklärt haben ihrer
freundin den restaurants den teureren
mittagessen als ich das dann für sie wie
ein hohen an wenn amerika sagt wir
müssen einfach wachstum das ist logisch
ja also von hinterhaus hofers jetzt
licht ausmachen flach atmen passiert gar
nichts ja also sparen das ist wie ein
hat der verhungerten sagst du deiner
soll weniger essen dass er die probleme
löst also ich sehe nur eins ja es ist ja
mittelstand es hin kleinunternehmer es
sind natürlich auch großkonzerne ärmel
hochkrempeln arbeit und schafe und
erwirbt versteuern und stirbt ok und
wenn man sehen was dabei rauskommt
herdorf sind würden sie zustimmen ihrem
kollegen herr meier bezüglich der
inflation ja also hat in vielen
bereichen recht insofern müssen wir da
nur versuchen das jetzt aktiv umzusetzen
und da sich die schwierigkeit aber ich
sehe auf die schwierigkeit natürlich bei
einer ampel geben wie soll das drei
verschiedene richtung die zusammen zu
kriegen ist dann nicht